hey Vsauce how you doing Michael here
first things first
did you see the story about Xbox banning
a guy for having offensive language in
his profile only to learn later that he
actually did live in Fort gay West
Virginia where you can read more about
it in the description the whole thing is
resolved now but the guy must feel so
lucky that he didn't also live on curly
dick Road alright let's get down to
business the entire point of this video
is that I wanted to share my five
favorite video game WTF dances obviously
when it comes to WTF dancing naked
similar jeez have everyone beat but that
doesn't mean that there can't be other
contenders so let's go ahead and start
with number 5 moonwalking in call of
duty modern warfare 2 number 4
dancing and LittleBigPlanet look look at
those guys there ok sorry that's just
humming next infamous has been a
treasure trove of awesome glitches but
my favorite is this girl look at her
look at her which reminds me of a video
I saw the character who was created for
Minecraft he's got some nice moves but
it looks like he's having the same kind
of seizure that that girl was having in
fact if this is the kind of dancing you
like I heard the easiest way to do it is
just get your head stuck in a tree let's
move on to something classy something
cultured and refined
how about Mass Effect 2 in ballet
and if ballets not your style maybe but
dancing is here's Laura cross to show us
yep okay number one okay this is my
favorite because it's not really a
glitch it's very effortful and it takes
some skill it's dancing inhaler
alright so that's my list let me know
below if there's any other type of WTF
you'd like me to cover next maybe maybe
it's just mods I'm having a lot of fun
with those right now
but anyway thank you guys for listening
and stay tuned tomorrow for a super
awesome nerve I'm looking forward to it
okay bye bye